der notruf eines kindes aus der schule
während der amokläufer um sich schießt
bist du verletzt fragt der polizist ja
ich wurde angeschossen antwortet das
kind 19 schüler und zwei lehrerinnen
sterben in der rob grundschule in you
well de
javier lopez war ein außergewöhnlicher
junger voller lebensfreude so beschreibt
ihn seine familie
nächste woche wird er zu grabe getragen
seine freundin or break noch immer nicht
begreifen was da eigentlich passiert ist
wir haben immer fangen zusammen gespielt
als der killer in der schule war habe
ich erst gar nicht verstanden was
passiert so etwas hätten wir nie
erwartet wir hatten solche angst vor dem
schützen es hat sich alles direkt vor
und neben unserem klassenraum zugetragen
[Musik]
und ihre großmutter kriegen die bilder
nicht mehr aus dem kopf die
schrecklichen szenen den horror vom 24
[Musik]
was an diesem tag passiert ist wird uns
nie mehr loslassen und in unseren
gedanken verfolgen es hätte genauso gut
meine enkeltochter hier treffen können
oder meine andere enkeltochter die in
der dritten klasse ist zum glück sind
sie okay es tut so weh ließen sie es tut
so weh dass all diese familien dadurch
müssen es bricht einem das herz
bilder von rabea lopez auch wenige
autostunden entfernt in houston vor dem
gebäude in dem der übermächtige waffen
verband nrl sein jahrestreffen abhält
gerade mal drei tage nach dem massaker
draußen protestieren sie während die
waffennarren drinnen ihre vorstellung
eines freien amerikas feiern
und auf ihr idol können sie immer zählen
während die mehrheit der amerikaner
schärfere waffengesetze fordert ist sein
credo aufrüsten stadt abrüsten
[Musik]
niemandem sollte es jemals möglich sein
in die nähe eines klassenzimmers zu
gelangen ohne vorher gründlich gecheckt
worden zu sein
und das wichtigste von nun an sollte
jede schule in amerika rund um die uhr
einen eigenen polizisten oder
bewaffneten sicherheitsbeamten haben
sein nachfolger als us präsident flog am
wochenende nach juval de es war ein
leiser besuch für manche zu leise lauter
hingegen werden die kritischen stimmen
die von joe biden fordern sich
entschlossener für gesetzesänderungen
stark zu machen seine demokraten hoffen
dabei auf rationale republikaner um
wenigstens einen minimalkonsens zu
erzielen
ihre appelle im senat hilflos bis hin zu
verzweifelt
versuchen sie sich in die haut dieser
eltern zu versetzen anstatt sich in den
armen des waffen verband zu wiegen das
hilft ihnen vielleicht sich aus den
fängen der nrw zu befreien vielleicht
schaffen sie es ja dann sich wenigstens
auf eine kleine maßnahme einzulassen im
sinne dieser kinder dieser 9 10 11
jährigen dieser wunderbaren kindern
bitte verdammt noch mal ich bitte sie
denken sie so als wären es ihre kinder
oder enkelkinder
nachbar kanada zeigt wie es auch laufen
kann innerhalb weniger tage hat die
regierung ein gesetz auf den weg
gebracht das kauf und verkauf von
handfeuerwaffen landesweit bis auf
weiteres auf eis legen soll außerdem
würde jeder den waffenschein verlieren
der häusliche gewalt begeht jemanden
stockt oder eine gefahr für sich oder
andere darstellt es gibt einfach keinen
grund dafür dass irgendjemand in kanada
eine waffe im alltag braucht und ganz
sicher brauchen kanadier keine
sturmgewehre die dafür gemacht sind
möglichst viele leute in kurzer zeit zu
tun
während kanada handelns spüren
republikanische waffenfreunde in amerika
zunehmend wut wie hier der texanische
senator ted cruise als er in einem
restaurant zu abend essen will
konfrontiert ihn ein waffengegner 19
kinder sind gestorben 19 kinder es liegt
in ihren händen
tote schüler scheinen im weltbild der
waffenlobby ein preis der freiheit zu
sein und sie gießen weiter öl ins feuer
so fordern die macher des sogenannten
american projekts waffenbesitzer auf
fotos ihrer liebsten schätze hochzuladen
jemaa cialis adipösen desto besser
reichweitenstarker wahnsinn während ein
großer teil der nation fassungslos um 19
kinder trauert groteske gegensätze
amerika inland in dem anscheinend
wirklich so ziemlich alles möglich ist
[Musik]
ich brauche christus singt der chor im
trauer park von new day
[Musik]
ich brauche deine kraft alles hier zu
überwinden
allein am vergangenen wochenende hat es
in den usa wieder mindestens zwölf
massen schießereien gegeben die mehrheit
der amerikaner sehnt sich nach einer
echten veränderung ihre hoffnung darauf
aber bleibt klein